وحاول تصعيد بين الصين والاتحاد الاوروبي
ايضا بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا للمره الاولى
وذلك منذ بدء الحرب على اوكرانيا يبدو ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي بات يشعر بقلق من تزايد
العلاقات الروسيه الصينيه حيث ذكرت صحيفه
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يعتزم فرض عقوبات على
الشركات الصينيه التي تدعم اله الحرب
الروسيه فوفقا للصحيفه جرى ادراج سبع
شركات صينيه متهمه ببيع معدات يمكن ان
تستخدم في صنع الاسلحه في حزمه جديده من
العقوبات التي ستناقشها الدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي خلال هذا الاسبوع تحتاج
قائمه العقوبات الى موافقه بالاجماع من
الدول الاعضاء التي يبلغ عددها سبعا
وعشرين دوله قبل ان يتم انفادها من المرجح
ان تثير هذه الخطوه خطوه الاتحاد الاوروبي
غضب بكين ففي اول رد منها قالت الصين انها
تعارض اي اجراءات تستخدم العلاقات الصينيه
الروسيه كذريعه لالحاق الضرر بها واضافت
انها ستتخذ اجراءات صارمه لحمايه مصالحها
اذا ما دخلت هذه العقوبات حيز التنفيذ
وتجنب الاتحاد الاوروبي حتى الان استهداف
الصين بحجه انه لا يوجد دليل يظهر انها
كانت تزود موسكو بالاسلحه بشكل مباشر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات